one of the most powerful features in all
firebase is its integration with Google
Analytics in this video I'll show you
how to collect sophisticated data about
the behavior of your users and then put
that data to use to custom tailor the
user experience and improve conversion
rates for whatever product you sell on
your app and if you're a web developer I
have great news because firebase just
recently added support for analytics on
the web if you're new here like and
subscribe and check out the full lesson
on fire ship i/o what we're going to do
today is enable Google Analytics in a
firebase project for the web and then
I'll show you how to log custom
analytics events in a JavaScript
application then they fast forward a
couple days into the future after we've
collected some data and use a service
called remote config to custom tailor
the user experience based on our
analytics data now if you're not already
using Google Analytics in your firebase
project you probably should be it's a
free service that provides insight about
the behavior of your users that will
ultimately drive your decisions about
marketing and the development of your
app and when it comes to firebase your
analytics data can enhance and unlock
other features in the platform for
example you can tie your analytics data
to your push notifications allowing you
to send the right notification to the
right user at the right time and as
we'll see in this video it unlocks a
feature that's new to the web called
remote config it provides a way for you
to read data related to your analytics
directly in your app that means you can
roll out experimental features to a
subset of users show conditional
marketing campaigns among a whole bunch
of other possibilities now let's go
ahead and get started by setting up our
web application with firebase analytics
the process is slightly different
depending on whether or not you already
have a Google Analytics account and a
firebase project so make sure to
reference the official Doc's depending
on your situation in my case I had an
existing firebase project that was also
already using Google Analytics so the
process to enable analytics in this
project was to click this begin upgrade
button that you'll see up here in the
top right corner of the analytics
dashboard when you click this button it
will have you click through a few pages
and then link your actual Google
Analytics project when you finish the
transfer process it's going to make one
small subtle change to your firebase
project settings if we go to the
Settings tab you'll know
that we now have a measurement ID
property in the firebase config so if
you have an existing app you'll want to
update this measurement ID in your
firebase config to get analytics working
in your project now I actually just set
up firebase analytics in this project a
couple days ago and what you'll notice
on the dashboard is that we're starting
to get reporting on the daily weekly and
monthly active users along with their
locations and all this reporting is now
combined across iOS Android and the web
now by simply adding analytics to your
project you will collect a bunch of data
automatically things like the user's
location at their operating system
browser and stuff like that there's a
bunch of different reports you can
explore here but my favorite one is
stream view it allows you to see where
your users are located on the map and
who's using the app in real time now
let's go ahead and take a look at the
actual setup for your typical JavaScript
application we have a very basic setup
here with an app KS and index.html file
most developers will be using a
framework like angular or react etc
which means you should have a
package.json file inside that package
you want to make sure that you update
firebase to version 7 or greater now in
this particular demo we're using
firebase hosting along with its magic
script tags in the index.html you'll
notice they're using firebase version 7
and I've imported firebase analytics as
well as firebase remote config now if we
jump into our actual JavaScript code the
first thing we'll want to do is
initialize firebase making sure that we
update our firebase config with the new
measurement ID and from there we'll call
firebase initialize app and then make a
reference to firebase analytics
these steps might look a little bit
different depending on your setup but
that's the gist of it update firebase to
version 7 and make a reference to
analytics so as a bare minimum you could
add analytics to your project and get
all this nice reporting and insight
about your users but the way you really
maximize the insight you gain about your
own specific app is to report custom
events now I'll just go ahead and set up
a hypothetical example here in our code
let's say we have the sign-in function
and its purpose is to sign the user and
anonymously or with email password or
Google login or something like that what
we'd like to do is report that a loggin
event has occurred so after the user
signs in we'll go ahead and extract the
sign-in method from the user credential
then we can call analytics log event
with the name of the event that we want
to log and then optionally as a second
argument we can pass an object with
additional parameters for that event
which in this case will be the login
method and it's also worth noting that
login is actually a built-in event in
Google Analytics so this technically
isn't a custom event it's generally
better to use a built-in event if it
fits your needs so make sure to check
out the Google Analytics reference for a
full list of events but if you don't see
the right event it's perfectly okay to
create your own custom event for example
imagine we're building a game and we
want to log a new game event to
analytics we call the same log event
method and pass the string name of our
event and then any optional parameters
as the second argument as an object and
that's really all there is to it when it
comes to reporting events when you start
collecting data you'll be able to see
that data in the events tab in the
firebase console you can optionally mark
events as conversions which would be
something like an in-app payment which
will help you manage your marketing
efforts towards that specific event
now you can generate reports for these
events and the custom parameters that
you report but the one thing worth
noting here is that if you have a custom
parameter you'll need to register it in
the firebase console you'll want to
click Edit parameter reporting and then
find a built in parameter or use one of
your custom parameters here and you'll
also notice when you add the parameter
it will ask you whether or not it's a
text or a number field text would be
used for discrete values or things that
can be counted like labels and then
numbers would be for continuous values
things like length time and currency
that can't be counted by can be averaged
out now if you're just getting started
with analytics I would recommend going
through your app and trying to find
maybe five to ten different events that
you can report that you think would be
useful to understanding the behavior of
your users you don't need to go
overboard with the number of events that
your report quality is always better
than quantity now in a lot of cases you
have a distinct set of events that you
expect the user to follow on the web you
might have a multi-step form and you
want to record a separate event for each
step in that form once you have that
done you can come to the funnels tab and
analyze how well that funnel actually
performs essentially you can connect one
event to another to see how the user
goes through those steps and see if
there's a certain step
where the user drops off or maybe one
that is more likely to convert to a
paying customer so now that we have some
custom events flowing through the app we
likely want to segment those events to a
smaller subset of users let's head back
over to the source code and I'll show
you how to set up something called a
user property and most firebase apps
you'll be listening to the current user
with the on/off state changed callback
when you listen to the current user
globally you can set the current user ID
by calling analytics set user ID with
the user object from the off state and
this allows analytics to collect
information about a specific user across
multiple sessions but you might have
additional things going on about a user
that you want to report to analytics for
example you might use something like
rule-based user access control so you
listen to the ID token and that ID token
will tell you whether or not that user
is an admin user or a moderator or
something along those lines and then you
can pass that data on to analytics so it
can segment your users based on this
custom user property one way to think of
this is that a user property defines
what a user is while an event defines
what a user does in the app and you can
set the user properties by simply
calling analytics set user properties
with an object of the data that you want
to set now when working with custom user
properties you'll want to go to the user
properties tab and register those
properties on the firebase console and
all you need to do is enter the string
name of the property the real benefit of
user properties comes into play when you
start building audiences let's head over
to the audience tab and create a new
audience
firebase will give you a bunch of hints
with default audiences but we'll just go
ahead and create a custom one from
scratch you can customize your audiences
based on events and user properties what
I want to do here is create an audience
of users that have triggered the login
event but that have a user property of a
pro membership that's canceled on fire
ship that would be a user that used to
be a member but that is still using the
site so maybe they want to sign up again
and if they do want to sign up we should
probably offer some kind of discount
code and that's exactly the type of
thing we can do with remote config head
over to the remote config tab and click
add new parameter a parameter is
essentially a key value pair but the
actual value is activated based on
some condition in your analytics data
set in this case we'll call it special
discount and then we'll add a new
condition for a veteran fire ship user
the first thing we'll do is set the app
equal to our web app and then we'll add
a second condition that is equal to one
of the user audience's that we created
on the firebase console and we could
also add a bunch of extra conditions
here as well if we wanted to segment it
by region or by device and we can even
sample it to a smaller subset of random
users for example in this case we'll
only offer the discount to a lucky 50%
of users and that feature happens to be
especially useful if you're rolling out
a new feature but you don't want to roll
it out to the entire user base all at
once and another cool thing about remote
config is that when you set up different
conditions you can reuse those
conditions across multiple parameters if
you go to the conditions tab you can see
all of your conditions there and update
them across all parameters at the same
time and now that we have some
parameters let's head back to our source
code and see how we can put them to use
in our JavaScript app we can reference
remote config in the STK by calling
firebase remote config and then you can
set a specific interval for how often it
fetches the values from remote config
it's not like the real time database or
fire store where it's constantly
listening for updates so just keep in
mind that changes to remote config
aren't instantaneous like they are in
other firebase services and it's also a
good idea to set up a default config
which are just default values in case
they can't be fetched from the firebase
servers from there we'll call fetch and
activate which will actually retrieve
the values from firebase and then it
provides type save getters that we can
use to read the actual values from
remote config so if we're expecting a
string value we can call remote config
get string followed by the parameter
name and you can do the same thing for
get boolean number and so on if you're
using a framework you would likely
retrieve these values somewhere high up
in the application like the app
component during your initial life cycle
hook and that would allow you to
conditionally render UI based on these
remote config file use I'm gonna go
ahead and wrap things up there we barely
just scratch the surface but it is very
awesome to finally see analytics and
remote config available for firebase
on the web that is thanks for watching
and I will talk to you soon
[Music]